they've been through weeks of untold
horrors in the bunkers and tunnels of
the azov style steel works in mariopol
this is the first group of evacuees to
make the perilous journey from
russian-controlled territory to the
ukrainian-controlled city of zapposia in
the red cross united nations convoy
you don't understand how terrible it was
you sit in the bomb shelter in a wet
basement and everything is shaking like
that and then when we could go up to the
surface i saw it for the second time in
a month a huge crater 15 meters wide and
who knows how deep
yes the military did share things with
us but it was the azov battalion so you
can imagine what they said we were told
that nobody needed us we felt abandoned
that we were nothing
for the past month supplies of food and
water have been severely rationed adults
going hungry for days to keep their
children fed
this is a moment of huge relief
russia said some evacuees have been
taken to a village controlled by
moscow-backed separatists and would be
allowed to travel to ukrainian held
territory if they wanted
but fears are growing for those left
behind in the confines of the steel
works
soon after the departure of the first
evacuees russian-backed forces resumed
their assault firing rockets towards the
plant
the mayor of mariopol says 200 civilians
still remain trapped inside including
several dozen small children
it's the last remaining area of the city
not under russian control
and the last refuge for hundreds of
ukrainian troops who refused to
surrender
the rest of mariopol is in ruins
but around a hundred thousand people
remain living amongst the rubble
tatiana
no longer flinches at the sound of
exploding shells
you wake up in the morning and you cry
you cry in the evening i don't know
where to go i am not alone here
imagine everything is destroyed where
should the people go now here they are
sitting with small kids
in the west of ukraine russia's launch
renewed attacks on the port city of
odessa where ukrainian officials say a
missile hit a children's dormitory
killing a 14 year old boy
missiles also struck a logistics center
used to deliver foreign weaponry
russia so far failed to land troops in
the city by sea
but seizing odessa would give russia
control of the whole of ukraine's black
sea coast
neve barker al jazeera